[Musik]
[Applaus]
willkommen zurück weil die damen und
herren ja mit dem einmarsch aller
musiken starken wir nun in den 2 den
konzertanten teil unseres militär
musikfestivals wie gefällt sie denn bis
jetzt
ich habe mir gerade sagen lassen ich
habe schon heute einige herrschaften
karten für die morgige vorstellung auch
wieder gekauft also das lob geht an euch
alle
manche leute kommen morgen ein zweites
mal um euch zu sehen
363 musiker und musikerinnen darunter 33
junge damen bitte stehen nun bereit sie
dürfen raten übrigens wer den größten
damen anteil unserer orchester hat das
verrate ich ihnen jetzt wieder später
denken sie mal darüber nach ja und
bestimmt haben die meisten von ihnen
schon im ersten teil ganz besondere
momente gehabt vielleicht eine gänsehaut
ist das so hat jemand schon gänsehaut
gehabt
dann kann ich nicht nur ihnen sondern
auch allen anderen gästen heute abend
versprechen spätestens jetzt im zweiten
teil wird es sie wirklich packen und sie
werden mitgerissen und wie sagt man so
schön auf österreichisch die horaffen um
ein stehplatz wahrscheinlich jetzt schon
bei dem ersten stück das ist eine solo
arien für blasorchester und sopran
komponist ist carl michael ziehrer des
175 geburtstag wir heuer feiern und
dieses stück stammt aus der operette der
verliebte sk drohen
und er singt für sie frau sabine hammer
und der name ist programm so viel kann
ich ihnen schon fahrer hatten dirigieren
und frau hammer exportieren zu ihrem
auftritt wird unser militärmusik chef
oberst magister bernhard her
meine damen und herren hier für sie das
gesamte große orchester gemeinsam mit
frau sabine hammer eine süße melodien
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dann stellt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die sprünge
[Applaus]
[Musik]
meine damen und herren
süßen melodien angst dirigentenpult
kommt jetzt gleich der militär
kapellmeister aus tirol oberst professor
johannes ab folter der diesen nächsten
part auch zusammengestellt und
arrangiert hat vorweg nur eines dieser
teil den sie jetzt gleich hören waren
trägt den titel in motions also
emotionen und sie mehr ist dem
eigentlich nicht hinzuzufügen lassen sie
es einfach auf sich wirken
ich finde ihn ganz ganz besonders schön
und freue mich jetzt drauf meine damen
und herren bitte schön
[Applaus]
[Musik]
warschau
jetzt
das war ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der sultan von brunei
[Musik]
sonnenschein
in der hand
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt sind
für mich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
damen und herren
überraschung gelungen war war eine
absolute premiere wo ein militär militär
musik kapellmeister als solist ich bin
so ergriffen als solist auftritt in dem
fall als sänger und noch am klavier sich
selber begleitet meine damen und herren
einen riesenapplaus für oberstleutnant
thema brannte aus kärnten
[Applaus]
dankeschön ich könnte euch alle ich
könnte euch alle posten aber das würde
den zeitlichen rahmen dieses abends
sprengen
mein sohn ist 17 wenn ich dem erzählt
das bundesheer auch so sein kann
verpflichtet das ich führe ich weiß
nicht wer also wirklich traumhaft
traumhaft schön wie geht's dir überhaupt
weiter ich bin jetzt auf ein konzept
jetzt wird das große orchester dirigiert
von oberstleutnant obendrauf er ist der
militär kapellmeister aus
niederösterreich an dieser stelle löse
ich auch gleich für sie auf ich habe sie
ja vorhin gefragt was meinen sie wer
welches orchester hat den größten damen
anteil hier im saal und das sind die
niederösterreicher mit zehn damen
[Applaus]
wir hören ein musterstück für posaunen
fans es nennt sich lass es schon bohn
und ist ein solostück für posaunen und
blasorchester vom komponisten henri
filme viel viel vergnügen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nein
[Applaus]
vielen dank acappella obendrauf und
einen riesenapplaus noch einmal für
unsere pensionisten und pensionistinnen
[Applaus]
meine damen und herren liebe gäste haben
irgendwie ein zwei kritische stimmen
gehört was diesen netten jungen manchmal
angeht wie heißt du denn der philipp ist
eigentlich mein hero irgendjemand meint
er hätte sich wenigstens eine uniform
anziehen können damit dass schicker
aussieht wenn er dadurch die rein läuft
aber er hat absolut seine
daseinsberechtigung weil er uns hier
gerade filmt und wir sind weltweit auf
facebook live zu sehen bitte und der
schlepper ungefähr wie viel kilo hat das
zeugs 20
ich glaube mehr mehr als 20 kilo durch
die gegend und das ist also wirklich für
mich in dieses etikett kameraleute immer
meine heroes lassen sie sich nicht
stören es ist eigentlich für guten zweck
und unter www bundesheer at können sie
alle fotos und auch alle aufnahmen die
der philipp für uns heute macht noch
einmal nachschauen jederzeit einen
applaus würfel
[Applaus]
man bringe ein schweißtuch ja meine
damen und herren als nächstes wird hier
am dirigentenpult der militär
kapellmeister aus schaut da ist es schon
dreh dich um philipp ich laufe mit
also ich hab mal ich habe mal so einen
um getanzt bei dancing stars echt jetzt
beim schönsten tanks denn wir hatten das
war der paso doble mit dieser karte an
diesem schönen tuch habe ich der ist er
hat aber nicht aufgepasst philipp der
war selber schuld
der ist im falschen moment angelaufen
gekommen und ich habe den durch
umgerannt weil unten drin sind so
bleigewichte in so eine charta eingenäht
interessiert dass jetzt gerade
irgendjemanden na ja wurscht jetzt habe
ich mich verlaufen
auf jeden fall habe ich den umgerannt
und das war also live auf sendung ein
garstiger sturz philipp toi toi toi
ja also herr oberst professor ernst
herzog unser salzburger militär
kapellmeister wird jetzt gleich am
dirigentenpult platz nehmen oder
aufstellung nehmen besser gesagt um was
müssen wir einmal heute noch richtig
zelebrieren hier in salzburg was sie
sein muss weil jeder veranstaltung hier
in salzburg der
danke meine damen und herren ich jetzt
immer aber wirklich mit singen gern mit
burschen hier kommt der rheiner marsch
vom komponisten professor hans schmid
das ganze große orchester bitte meine
herren und damen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
danke schön sehr